ja in der heutigen Vorlesung geben erst
noch einen Rückblick auf die letzte
Sitzung
wir hatten es mit dem Begriff des
Willens noch mal zu tun wir haben uns
bezogen auf ein ganz klassischen Text
von Harry Frankfurt musst du ja 1971
also 50 Jahre alt über 50 Jahre alt
dieser Text ein echter klassischer Text
und gibt es natürlich mittlerweile auch
schon deutsche Übersetzung aber ich
empfehle immer in möglichst auf Englisch
zu lesen der Einfachheit halber werde
ich aber jetzt heute vor allem englische
Zitate nicht verwenden sondern eben
deutsche ja wir haben jetzt hier schon
so ein bisschen gesehen dass der Text
nicht ganz einfach ist der ist durchaus
kompliziert ich fasse noch mal zusammen
also der Wille ist nach Harry Frank für
dasjenige passend zu einer Person macht
und nicht der Selbstbewusstsein ich sage
nur John Lock den haben wir mal
behandelt die individuelle Person und
auch nicht die Vernunft sondern die
Vernunft ist es was wir immer schon
voraussetzen müssen
Strom überhaupt ein solchen komplexen
Willen zu entwickeln von dem Harry
friend von spricht man kann letztendlich
sagen Harry Frankfurt argumentiert für
ein reflexives willensmodell reflexiv
heißt wir haben schon mal dieses diesen
Begriff hier
kennengelernt dass wir in der Lage sind
volitionen zweiter Stufe auszubilden und
darauf wollen wir heute noch ein
bisschen genauer eingehen das ist so das
Stichwort natürlich auch eine sehr gute
Frage für die Klausur vom Typ A
natürlich
also auch noch mal wichtige Willens
Struktur der Wille ist nicht einfach
irgendwas ganz einfaches und ganz
simples sind der Wille von Personen
zumindest der ist komplex der Wille ist
reflexiv der Wille ist in sich
differenziert wir haben es mit Wünschen
zu tun und mit volitionen und darauf
werden wir jetzt noch näher zu sprechen
kommen also der Unterschied zwischen
Personen und anderen Kreaturen hier
natürlich wieder Übersetzungsproblem
creatures oder wie soll man übersetzen
ja anderen Lebewesen ist weil ich das
Beste an liegt in der Struktur des
Willens einer Person und jetzt bringt er
noch ein Begriff nämlich Personen sind
in der Lage
Wünsche zweiter Stufe also die sei
second order desires ist das englische
Wort dafür auszubilden das müssen wir
uns genau überlegen was ist das also was
ist der Unterschied zwischen Wunsch
zweiter Stufe und volitionen auch nicht
ganz tolle Klausur Frage die man für den
Typ A verwenden könnt ja also ich lese
noch so jemand hat ein Wunsch zweiter
Stufe wenn er entweder einfach ein
bestimmten Wunsch haben möchte oder wenn
er möchte dass ein bestimmter Wunsch
sein Wille sein diesen zweiten kann also
wenn ich möchte dass ein bestimmter
Wunsch mein Wille sein und der Wille ist
nachher mit Frank wird immer etwas was
handlungswirksam ist also Wille muss man
von Wunsch unterscheiden auch eine ganz
ganz tolle Klausur Frage was ist der
Unterschied zwischen Wille und Wunsch
zum Beispiel nach Harry friends oder
auch generell das ist einfach eine
begriffliche Klärung die so allgemein
anerkannt ist dass man zwischen Wunsch
und Wille unterscheiden muss also wenn
wir volitionen zweiter Stufe haben dann
wollen wir tatsächlich zu einer Handlung
gelangen und nicht nur uns etwas
wünschen wünschen kann ich mir vieles
ich kann mir wünschen es wäre jetzt hier
draußen ich wäre jetzt hier in der
Südsee das kann ich mir wünschen aber
will ich es auch wirklich um es zu
wollen müsste ich am jetzt sie leider
hier verlassen müsste ich alles stehen
und liegen lassen müsste ich Geld
abheben müsste ich zum Flughafen fahren
das heißt ich müsste ziemlich viele
Dinge unternehmen Stichwort
instrumentelle Vernunft das führt dann
schon zum nächsten Thema ich müsste also
auch meine Vernunft anstrengen und mir
überlegen welche Mittel muss ich genau
ergreifen um zu diesem Ziel zu kommen
also ein Wille zu haben bedeutet immer
mehr zu machen als ein bösen Wunsch zu
haben wir können Sie auch anders
bezeichnen wer ein Wille hat der richtet
sich auf etwas als der muss sehr
verbindlich Dinge in den Angriff nehmen
und ja also das ist so der Punkt und er
bringt auch noch einen anderen Begriff
den Begriff des triebhaften one ton auch
wieder eine spannende Frage für Typ A
was ist nach Harry Frankfurt ein one-ton
und warum ist er keine Person so kann
man auch fragen dann ein one-ton der mag
vielleicht Wünsche
zweiter Stufe haben also er mag sich
wünschen etwas zu wünschen ein Wunsch zu
haben das ist unter Umständen möglich
aber er hat keine volitionen zweite
Stufe das heißt der bleibt nur auf der
Ebene der Wünsche stehen und der
verpflichtet sich nie auf etwas was man
eben jetzt Munition zweite Stufe nennen
würde wir müssen das jetzt noch mal
genauer anschauen also es gibt den
Unterschied zwischen der Person und dem
triebhaften und hat hier ziehen sich
noch an die letzte Vorlesung wir hatten
hier ein sehr sehr spannendes Beispiel
von zwei Drogenabhängigen
Menschen ich sage jetzt nicht Personen
weil nach Harry friend wird der eine
drogenabhängig keine Person ist und das
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen
problematisch aber gehen wir mal so ein
bisschen drauf ein als es gibt zwei
Drogensüchtige die haben genau dieselben
Bedingungen der sucht ja und sie
erliegen auch beide auf diese
letztendlich der sucht sie nehmen am
Ende die Droge es ist nur der
Unterschied der eine der uns jetzt hier
geht der der kämpft unablässig
verzweifelt aber erfolglos gegen die
Macht der sucht er probiert alles wovon
von der meint es können ihn befähigen
sein Verlangen nach der Droge zu
überwinden aber dieser Wunsch ist zu
mächtig er kann ihn nicht widerstehen er
ist ein Süchtiger wieder Willen also das
ist jetzt spannend da hat als ein eine
drogensüchtige Person in sich
wieder streitende Wünsche der ersten
Stufe sagt es Frankfurt also ich habe
auf der
basalen Ebene meiner
Strebungen meiner Bewegung Menschen das
was ich unmittelbar in mir wo findet da
hat er wieder strebende wünscht also hat
den Wunsch betrogen zu nehmen
und er möchte auch sie nicht nehmen hat
den Wunsch nicht
umsichtig zu sein also nicht der Droge
letztendlich süchtlicherweise
ausgeliefert zu sein und das muss man
sich jetzt nach helfen Frankfurt auf
derselben Ebene vorstellen ich first
order am ersten Stufe und jetzt hatte
aber noch
auf einer zweiten Stufe also nicht auf
dieser widerstrebenden Ebene Droge
nehmen Wunsch möchte eigentlich nicht
sind auf einer zweiten Ebene hat er
jetzt noch eine volition zweite Stufe er
steht nämlich so Fremdwort dem
Widerstreit seiner Wünsche die Droge zu
nehmen und auch von ihr abzulassen das
ist auf der ersten Stufe die
widerstrebenden Wünsche nicht neutral
gegenüber und jetzt wenn er nicht
neutral dieser ersten
gegenübersteht dann haben wir es mit
einer second order einer zweiten Ebene
zu tun er möchte nämlich dass der zweite
Wunsch der Wunsch nicht Drogen zu nehmen
und nicht der erste Wunsch der erste
Wunsch ist der Wunsch Drogen zu nehmen
also dass der zweite Wunsch sein will es
sei möchte also dass er die Droge nicht
nimmt die Droge nicht zu nehmen könnte
man sagen ist eine Unterlassung ja also
er möchte praktisch eine Unterlassung
betreiben und wir hatten darüber
diskutiert im Seminar eine Unterlassung
und auch etwas nicht zu tun kann eine
Handlung sein also möchte praktisch
letztendlich eine Handlung vollziehen
und er möchte ein handlungswirksamen
Wunsch entwickeln oder ja genau
entwickelt eine Einstellung gegenüber
seinem Wunsch der letztendlich
erwillentlich ist weil er nämlich zu
einer auf eine Handlung hin abzielt er
möchte sagt Terry Frankfurt dass ich der
zweite Wunsch die Droge nicht zu nehmen
durchsetzt und den Zweck abgebe den er
durch das was er wirklich tut zu
erreichen so das ist jetzt ganz spannend
also selbst wenn jetzt eine Person am
Ende doch die muss man immer schauen was
es letztendlich ihr im Kopf oder genauer
gesagt in ihrem Willen weil der Wille
ist ja Komplex eine willenstruktur
vorgegangen gab es da einen Streit einen
Kampf eine Reflexion und wenn die
Reflexion stattgefunden hat also every
Frank wird spricht auch von einer
Identifikation als sie die
Drogensüchtige Person wieder Willen die
identifiziert sich mit einem Ihrer
Wünsche nämlich mit dem zweiten Wunsch
auf der Passage sie könnte sich auch mit
einem anderen Wunsch identifizieren es
geht immer darum wie identifizieren wir
uns von einer zweiten Stufe mit einem
Wunsch auf der ersten Stufe sie hat eine
identifikationsleistung verbracht auch
wenn sie am Ende nicht zur Handlung
gelungen ist gekommen ist man kann jetzt
diskutieren warum sie nicht zu handeln
kommen ist war das vielleicht sowas wie
Willensschwäche wird auch ein eigenes
Thema sein jedenfalls hat sie sich
identifiziert mit einem Ihrer Wünsche
und zwar so dass sie wollte dass der
Wunsch ihr Wille sei dann war es
rollition zweiter Stufe und wir haben
gel nachher in Frankfurt ist eine Person
die volition zweiter Stufe ausbilden
oder ein Wesen was koalitions weiter
Stufe ausbildet eine Person und jetzt
gibt es halt noch ein anderes einen
anderen Fall wir haben ja genau
dieselben physiologischen Bedingungen
also der sucht die sind genau gleich
strukturiert der andere Süchtige ist ein
triebhaftes Wesen nach Hilfe von einem
one town seine Handlungen spiegeln die
Ökonomie seiner Wünsche der ersten Stufe
ohne dass es ihm kümmert ob die Wünsche
die ihn zum Handeln treiben auch Wünsche
sind
durch die er sich zum Handeln veranlasst
sehen möchte
das heißt der hat gar keinen wirkliche
Identifikation zu seinem Willen ihm ist
der Wille letztendlich gleichgültig es
findet keine second order-bolischen
Stadt und deswegen sagt er unterscheidet
sich dieser Drogenhund Süchtige was
seine triebhafte Unbekümmertheit angeht
nicht von einem Tier das kann man
natürlich auch bestreiten ja das kann
man mit guten Gründen bestreiten und
hier mache ich meine kurze Pause dass
wir hier drüber diskutieren können
interessant ist jetzt bei Harry
Frankfurt das Wünsche zweiter Ordnung
eben nicht unbedingt handlungswirksam
sein müssen
selbst eigentlich genau genommen auch
volition zweiter Stufe wie wir jetzt bei
dem Drogenabhängigen gesehen haben der
hat ja volition zweiter Stufe und
trotzdem kommt er nicht zu einer
Handlung ich mache gerade noch weiter
und dann können wir darüber diskutieren
aber also jedenfalls sind Wünsche
zweiter Stufe nicht auf eine Handlung
ausgerichtet so muss man sagen ja also
volition zweite Stufe sind
Konzentration Identifikation die auf
eine Hand ausgerichtet sind und es ist
bei Wünschen der zweiten Stufe nicht und
jetzt bringt er das Beispiel nehmen wir
an Arzt der sich mit der
psychotherapeutischen Behandlung von
Drogensüchtigen befasst glaubt dass er
seinen Patienten besser helfen könnte
wenn er besser verstanden wie es für sie
ist den Wunsch nach der Droge zu haben
der sie süchtig sind
nehmen wir weiter an der komme auf diese
Weise dazu dass er selber den Wunsch
nach der Droge haben möchte wenn nun was
er haben möchte wirklich ein richtiger
Wunsch ist dann möchte er nicht nur die
Gefühle haben wie der Süchtige
charakteristischerweise erleben wie sie
sich die erleben wenn Sie Ihr Verlangen
nachhaltigen gepackte Arzt möchtest dass
wenn ein solches Verlangen haben möchte
in einem gewissen Maße die Neigung
verspüren oder dazu gedrängt werden die
Droge zu nehmen das ist jetzt ganz
interessanter Fall aber sowas gibt es
eben auch und das sind jetzt hier eben
nicht volitionen zweiter Stufe der Arzt
möchte natürlich nicht drogensüchtig
sein sondern der Arzt möchte einfach
wissen wie es ist einfach mal den Wunsch
zu haben ertrugen zu nehmen und jetzt
lese ich noch das nächste dazu vor und
dann können wir diskutieren es ist aber
durchaus möglich dass er obwohl er von
dem Verlangen nach der Droge gedrängt
sein möchte
und zweiter Stufe doch nicht möchte dass
ein Verlangen handlungswirksam sein also
keine volitionsrate
vielleicht möchte er nicht dass in sein
Wunsch den ganzen Weg zur
Ausführung der Handlung gehen lässt es
braucht ihm nicht zu interessieren wie
es ist die Droge zu nehmen und insofern
ein nun bloß wünscht dass er die Drogen
nehmen möchte aber nicht sie zu nehmen
möchte er nichts was nur die Droge
selber geben könnte er kann also in der
Tat den ganz eindeutigen Wunsch haben
die Droge nicht zu nehmen und er wird
klug alles so arrangieren dass es ihm
unmöglich wird den Wunsch zu befriedigen
den er haben würde falls ein Wunsch das
Verlangen nach der Droge zu haben einmal
Erfüllung ging ja oder ist jetzt
ziemlich ziemlich kompliziert
ausgedrückt wir lesen noch ein Zitat es
wäre also nichtig aus der Tatsache dass
der Arzt wünscht dass Verlangen nach
einer Probe zu haben zu schließen dass
er auch schon wirklich verlangt sie zu
nehmen sein Wunsch zweiter Stufe zu
Droge getränkt zu werden schließt nicht
ein dass er einen Wunsch erste Stufe hat
die Droge zu nehmen würde man ihm nun
die verabreichen so brauchte diese Art
keinen Wunsch zu befriedigen denn seinem
Wunsch enthalten wäre ein Verlangen nach
der Truppen zu haben während er möchte
dass sie die Droge nehmen möchte braucht
er nicht den Wunsch zu haben sie zu
nehmen es kann sein dass er nichts
weiter möchte als das Verlangen nach ihr
zu kosten das heißt also sein Wunsch
einen bestimmten Wunsch zu haben den er
nicht hat braucht nicht ein Wunsch zu
sein dass sein Wille im mindestens ein
anderer ist als der der ist oh jetzt
haben wir hier ein ganz spannendes Zitat
und jetzt machen wir gleich eine kleine
Diskussion drüber das ist sicherlich
diskussionswürdig
wir haben gesehen man kann jetzt auch
Wünsche zweiter Stufe ausbilden wie
diese Art der hat der wünscht sich
einfach mal den Wunsch zu haben
drogensüchtig zu sein ohne dass er die
Drogen nehmen möchte ist aber ein sehr
seltener Fall so was kommt sicherlich
sehr selten vor aber es belegt doch wie
ich finde sehr gut dieses Modell von
Harry francer
wir haben schon noch mal hier gesehen
also er sagt jetzt dass eben kleine
Kinder praktisch keine volition zweite
Stufe ausbilden können ja und
dementsprechend keine Personen sind
natürlich immer davon ab was man jetzt
unter Person versteht ich persönlich bin
ein bisschen kritisch ich vertrete die
Position das auch kleine Kinder Personen
sind ich mache es aber deswegen nicht am
Willen von Willen abhängig von anderen
Dingen er hat da eben ein sehr engen
speziellen Personen ja also darum
worüber müssen wir noch mal genauer
diskutieren ob mit den Personenbegriff
auch sowas wie würde er geht das würde
jetzt aber erstmal zu weit führen also
jetzt haben wir hier so ein bisschen das
gesehen
und was auch noch wichtig ist was wir
vorhin möchte ist diese diese reflexive
Ebene von der aus wir uns beziehen auf
unsere Wünsche erste Stufe und uns dann
identifizieren diese reflexiv Ebene
müssen nicht moralisch sein ja das sagte
hier also es muss keine moralische
Einstellung sein könnte ja denken nur
dann entwickle ich volition zweite Stufe
wenn ich objektive Kriterien habe und
mich dann von dieser Ebene her mit
meinen Wünschen identifiziert die
moralisch sind letztendlich und die
moralischen interpretierbar sind da
sagte nein also die zweite Stufe die
reflexive Stufe muss nicht eine
moralischen Stufe sein ich kann auch aus
anderen Gründen nicht identifizieren aus
persönlichen kommen ja das können ganz
verschiedene Motive sein es müssen nicht
moralische Motive sein das ganz
interessant weil die Manuel kann
vertritt eher so die Gegenteile geht
gegen these an der sagt die volition
zweiter Stufe kann spricht nicht davon
aber so könnte man interpretieren das
muss eine moralische Stufe sein
ja
er bringt hier noch so ein bisschen was
wie eine Willens Paralyse also er sagt
jetzt gibt es verschiedene Probleme oder
kann man auch noch eine Tutorien genauer
diskutieren es kann zum Beispiel sein
dass wir Wünsche zweiter Stufe haben die
sich selbst wieder streiten ja dann ist
der betroffen in Gefahr keine volition
zweiter Stufe zu haben es gibt auch
nicht nur ein Konflikt auf der ersten
Stufe sondern Konflikt auf der zweiten
Stufe ich weiß nicht was ich mir
wünschen soll ich habe den Wunsch diesen
Wunsch mir zu wünschen und ich habe den
Wunsch mit diesen Wunsch zurück ja und
was ist dann ja das heißt dann haben wir
hier so eine Art von Willens Paralyse
hier spricht von der Gefahr einer
Willens Paralyse und vollständigen
Untätigkeit auch das können wir dann im
Folgenden noch genauer diskutieren wenn
es um Willensschwäche gibt und dann gibt
es noch ein anderes Problem das ist
nennt er die Zerstörung der Person
und zwar das habe ich auch schon mal
angedeutet
wenn wir jetzt uns Identifizieren von
der zweiten Stufe
dann aber oder wollen und identifizieren
wir haben aber auf der zweiten Stufe
auch
konfligierende Interessen also wir haben
auf der zweiten Stufe ein Widerstreit
sagt er hier und Wünschen zweiter Stufe
dann müssten wir praktisch versuchen von
einer noch höheren Ebene mit uns zu
identifizieren mit den Wünschen zweiter
Stufen also müssten volitionen Dritter
Stufe sozusagen ausbinden die dass ich
dann auf die volition auf die Wünsche
zweiter Stufe beziehen und jetzt kann
man natürlich sagen vielleicht habe ich
auch der dritten Stufe auf die Ebene von
Wünschen Dritter Stufe wieder
konfligierende Wünsche dann brauche ich
volitionen vierter Stufe und es könnte
ja prinzipiell immer weiter gehen wie
sie uns endlich ja und ja und dann sagt
das so was würde auch zu einer
Zerstörung der Person führen ja die
kennen nie zu einer Handlung die würde
sich ich letztendlich immer wieder bis
uns endlich ihren Willen weiter
reflektieren das könnte man auch als ein
Fall von Willensschwäche diskutieren
wenn wir dann soweit sind möchtest nur
in die Diskussion geben darüber kann man
wunderbar weiter diskutieren und auch da
gibt es verschiedene Auffassung davon
gibt es ganz verschiedene verif
Frankfurt hat eine eigene these dazu der
sagt es genügt von der zweiten Ordnungs
zu machen wir müssen uns einfach
entschieden festlegen das spricht von
einem designsive Act und jetzt kann man
natürlich da wiederum dagegen sagen dass
doch bloße Willkür haben einige
ForscherInnen Forscher das hat sich dann
dazu entscheiden das nicht mehr weiter
zu reflektieren wieso soll ich nicht
noch mal von der Loch hören Ebene
reflektieren sagt irgendwann müssen wir
aufhören und zweite Stufe reicht
ja soweit zu Harry Frank führt dann
gehen wir noch mal hier ein bisschen
zurück auf das Thema Gründe
ihr habt gesagt Gründe sind die Antwort
auf die Frage warum eine Person etwas
getan hat Willkür hatte ich schon aber
wenn sie sagen darum basta dann haben
sie eine willkürposition sie
rechtfertigen ihre Handlung nicht sie
sagen einfach nur ich habe es getan weil
ich es getan habe weil sie kennen
vielleicht von Martin Luther den Spruch
hier stehe ich ich kann nicht anders es
war glaube ich ein Worms Frage ist das
Willkür können wir auch noch drüber
diskutieren man kann auch von einer
willentlichen Notwendigkeit sprechen von
einer ganz starken Identifikation die
gar keine weiteren Gründe mehr braucht
jetzt habe ich da verschiedene Bedeutung
von grundunterschieden also wie kann ich
auch schon sagen das wird jetzt nicht
jetzt in der Klausur so abgefragt werden
an dass sie diese fünf alle nennen
sondern da wird man auch eher eine
Diskussion gehen können ich will ihn nur
so ein paar Aspekte nennen und auch ein
bisschen ausführen also Gründe
kann man sagen Gründe können gute Gründe
sein zwingende Gründe oder Gründe können
sogar auch moralische Gruppe sein es
betrifft wieder die Frage jetzt ob wir
von der zweiten Stufe die Harry Frank
wird zwar keine moralischen
Erwägung treffen müssen oder eben auch
was sind gute Gründe gute Gründe sind
immer zwingende Gründe also die sind
einfach schlagende Gründe ich will jetzt
einfach mal von den Bedeutung von Grund
herkommen dann können Sie aber auch ein
Grund so perspektivieren von der
Handlung dass sie sagen dieser Grund hat
mich motiviert das war der
handlungswirksamkeit und das hat mich
motiviert das hat mich zu Handlung
bewegt häufig sind dann ich komme noch
genauer drauf häufig auch Emotionen mit
dem Spiel die man vielleicht sogar auch
als Gründe verstehen kann dann kann man
auch ganz allgemein von kausalen Gründen
sprechen jetzt nicht unbedingt mit Blick
auf Handlungen so wenn Sie fragen warum
brennt der Baum können sagen ja weil der
Blitz eingeschlagen hat es natürlich der
kausale Grund der hat aber natürlich
nichts mit einer Handlung zu tun der
Blitz hat hier nicht gehandelt und man
auch noch rationale Gründe versuchen es
unterscheiden das sind Gründe die zu tun
haben mit Urteilen und Schlüssen auf die
beste Handlung
Urteil und Schlüssel haben auch was mit
Gründen zu tun und wir können auch
explicativ oder erklärende Grund
unterscheiden wenn sie anderen Personen
dann letztendlich ihre Handlungsmotive
darlegen und im Zusammenhang es tun ich
gehe jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen noch
näher drauf ein auf die normativen
Gründe wir handeln in der Regel dann
wenn wir gute Gründe für eine Handlung
haben grundsätzlich muss ich sagen sie
haben häufig mehrere Gründe sie haben
nicht nur ein Grund ja stellen sich das
Ganze vor wie so eine Waagschale sie
haben ein Wille der Wille ist ein Mark
eine Waage die hat zwei Schalen ist
jetzt ein bisschen vereinfacht
dargestellt wird eine Geschichte der
Philosophie häufig gemacht und sie
können jetzt Gründe wieso kleine
Gewichte sich vorstellen sie kennen doch
bestimmt noch so spielzeugwaren oder
auch im Kaufladen früher da gab es dann
so kleine Gewichtssätze
Diagramm 10 Gramm 20 Gramm und dann
können Sie so die Gewichte in die
waagschein werfen und dann sehen Sie mal
irgendwie schlägt sie dann aus sie
können Sie jetzt mal vorläufig einen
Grund wieso ein kleines Waag Gewicht
vorstellen ein Grund ist etwas was sie
in die willenswaage legen können was
ausschlaggebend kann für die Neigung
ihrer willenswaage das ist ein Grund und
es gibt natürlich Gründe die hat
stärkeres Gewicht metaphorisch
gesprochen jetzt oder Gründe die haben
ein schwächeres Gewicht deswegen müssen
sie auch Gründe Abwägen der liberieren
das heißt unser Handeln richtet sich
nach Normen und Wertesystemen die häufig
individuelle manchmal auch über
individuelle Geltung haben was für sie
ein Grund ist mag für eine andere Person
kein Grund sich sein wenn wir jetzt
nicht sagen wir reden von moralischen
weil es gibt eine Philosophie die
Auffassung moralische Gründe sind immer
gute Gründe die gelten universell
sozusagen das ist ein Spezialfall aber
in der Regel wenn sie sagen ich hatte
diesen Grund dafür dann kann die andere
Person das schon verstehen wenn sie
rechtfertigen und System ihre anderen
Gründe aber die Person könnte sagen also
mich wäre das jetzt keinen Grund gewesen
das hängt natürlich immer davon ab was
für eine individuelle Situation sie
haben was für ein Wertesystems ja
was von einem bestimmten bestimmten Fall
gut ist hängt von unseren spezifischen
Interessen von unserer von unserer
wunschbasis von dem was wir auf der
Ebene Wünsche erste Ordnung vorfinden
das habe ich schon gesagt in der
Philosophie gibt es manchmal die These
das ist auch Gründe gibt die absolut gut
und zwingend sind und die nicht von
unseren individuellen Interessenslagen
abhängen also ob ich mir jetzt hier
sozusagen ob ich wenn ich jetzt Hunger
habe dann
gehe ich runter in die Cafeteria und
kauf mir da irgendwas Essen das ist dann
instrumentelle Rationalität da muss ich
ein Mittel zu einem Zweck
verwenden dann habe ich praktisch Gründe
die abhängig sind von individuellen
Interessen wenn es um die Frage geht ob
ich lügen soll zum Beispiel könnte ich
doch sagen ich habe einen guten Grund zu
lügen warum könnte ich einen guten Grund
haben zu lügen z.B um eine anderen
Person eine Peinlichkeit zu ersparen das
ist das nur Notlüge sie können sich eine
Peinlichkeit ersparen wenn Sie den
Notlüge machen jeder von uns lügt ich
habe meine Umfrage gesehen ich glaube
die wechselt so die die Forschung sagt
zwischen 100 und 50 Mal oder so lügen
wir pro Tag ja könnte man ach googeln ja
jedenfalls lügen wir permanent die
meisten von uns aber ohne irgendwas Mora
unmoralisches damit zu beabsichten wenn
wir lügen dann lügen wir häufig um den
Alltag einfach angenehm zu machen ist
einfach Höflichkeit oder not jetzt
würden aber manche sagen mir zum
Beispiel Manuel Kant lügen ist
intrinsisch ein schlechter Grund lügen
kann nie ein guter Grund sein lügen ist
als solches per se falsch lügen ist kein
guter Grund lügen ist unordentlich es
gibt keine Situation in der zu lügen ein
guter Grund für eine Handlung wäre ein
guter Grund wäre wir diskutieren gleich
das sagt Immanuel Kant es heißt das will
ich einmal noch zu bedenken manche
werden gute Gründe auch als absolut gute
Gründe verstehen ja also moralische
Gründe
solche Gründe werden häufig moralische
Gründe genannt und wir kommen auch noch
näher auf den kategorischen Imperativ
haben Sie schon mal gehört da kommen wir
heute noch ein bisschen drauf aber wenn
es um unser Handeln geht dann gibt es
motivierende Gründe das sind
handlungswirksame Gründe wenn man also
jetzt überlegt was hat mich bewegt
vom bloßen Willen zur konkreten Handlung
zu gehen was war am Ende
ausschlaggebend ja den anderen Gründen
praktisch den Grund vorzuziehen Gründe
nehmen auch häufig dann die Gestalt von
volitional also willentlichen
emotionalen Zuständen an die etwa Liebe
oder Mitleid wenn wir auf den
motivationalen Aspekt uns beziehen
kausale Gründe hatte ich schon genannt
das ist jetzt nicht so sehr auf die
Handlung bezogen sondern es betrifft
jetzt nicht dass er die guten Gründe
sondern ihr die Ursache also der die
Ursache für das Brennen des Baumes ist
der einst das der Einschlag des Blitzes
da kann man jetzt nicht mehr von guten
Gründen reden die sind einfach kausale
Gründe da ist was passiert das heißt in
der Philosophie ist die Frage umstritten
ob grün jetzt für unser Handeln her
gesehen ob die auch als kausale Ursachen
verstanden werden können ob ein Grund
adäquat als kausale Ursache zu verstehen
ist in Analogie dazu wie der Blitz die
kausale Ursache für das brennendes
Waldes ist können wir nach dieser
kausalen Logik auch Gründe verstehen in
uns einfach nur so kausale Faktoren sind
das Gründe ich glaube nicht aber auch
das wird dann wenn überhaupt eine Frage
des Typs sein da brauchen sie keine
Sorge zu haben das ist keine Frage des
Typs ah weil man darüber riesige
Diskussion führen kann ich möchte Ihnen
einfach nur ein paar Perspektiven zeigen
das heißt
pauschale Gründe müssen nicht immer auf
unsere Handeln bezogen werden wie ich
genannt hatte im Beispiel des Blitzes da
hat es nicht ein Handlung zu tun da gibt
es keine Intentionen keine Absichten
aber es gibt Gründe kausale Gründe mit
denen wir ein eigenes erklären können
aber nicht verstehen können also das ist
noch eine wichtige Differenz erklären
und verstehen häufig sagt man um was zu
verstehen brauche ich gründe im Sinne
zum Beispiel der guten Gründe der
normativen Gründe dann kann ich eine
Person verstehen erklären wäre jetzt
aber eine Person so zu betrachten wie
den brennenden Baum nur nach solchen
Wirkmechanismus und das ist wird
irgendwie nicht den der Handlungslogik
einer Person gerechnet also muss
zwischen dem kausal erklären dem
naturkausein erklären wie bei einem
Blitz unterscheiden und dem subjektiven
verstehen und unterscheiden wobei man
sich auch ein bisschen die Person hinein
fühlen kann was war in ihre
Interessenlage was war ihr Wertesystem
und nur darin werden dann Gründe als
solche verständlich gute Gründe für die
Person wir diskutieren da gleich noch
bisschen genauer drüber rationale Gründe
ist auch so ein Aspekt wir können Gründe
unter dem Gesicht und ihrer Rationalität
versuchen zu verstehen hier wieder der
Unterschied zwischen verstehen und
erklären
Gründe sind insofern rational als sie
aus Schlüssen Abwägung und Kalkulationen
sich ergeben die gewissen
rationalitätsstandards genügen also
häufig wegen sie was ab und schließen
dann darauf dass das angesichts ihres
Zieles jetzt die beste Option wäre dann
sind sie Rationalität tätig betrifft
auch noch das Thema praktische Vernunft
dass wir auch noch eingehen hier stellt
sie natürlich wieder die Frage sind
jetzt rationale Gründe immer auch
moralische Gründe oder gibt es auch
rationale Gründe Gründe für etwas für
eine Handlung Gründe die für etwas
sprechen
die nicht Moral an moralischen
orientiert sind die große Debatte gibt
es absolut moralische Gründe oder eben
müssen Gründe immer letztendlich
moralisch sein oder eben nicht
dann kann man noch explikative erklären
Gründe unterscheiden erklärend jetzt
nicht so zu verstehen wie das
naturkausal erklären das Blitzes im Baum
sondern sie kennen das wenn man sagt
erkläre dich mal erkläre dich wenn sie
sich erklären also damit ist gemein wenn
sie ihre Handlung rechtfertigen ja wenn
sie ihre Handlung rechtfertigen dann
versuchen sie ihre subjektiven Gründe
die Gründe die sie bewogen haben anhand
ihre Interessenslage möglichst objektiv
anderen Personen so dazu darzustellen
dass sie es nachvollziehen können das
ist verstehen können und sie versuchen
sich zu verteidigen gegenüber von
Einwänden also warum hast du das so und
so getan wenn Sie das gefragt werden
versuchen Sie sich zu rechtfertigen
durch rechtfertigende
Lehrende Gründe weil das und das und
dann war noch das und deswegen habe ich
das gemacht so werden sie dann der Regel
sich rechtfertigen und indem sie ihre
Handlung rechtfertigen erzählen sie eine
möglichst kohärente Geschichte als eine
Geschichte die sie nicht widerspricht
sondern die nachvollziehbar ist die auch
für außenstehende Personen verständlich
ist deine eine Geschichte ein narrativ
das heißt nicht alle Gründe die wir in
Betracht ziehen müssen zu einer Handlung
führen es kann sein sie sagen das wäre
möglicher Grund aber das mehr spricht
noch mehr dazu ja häufig sagen auch
Philosophen wie zum Beispiel der
Konstanzer Philosoph Peter Stemmer sagt
Gründe sind dasjenige was für etwas
spricht ein Grund spricht immer für
etwas
aber es gibt natürlich stärkere und
schwächere Gründe manche Dinge manche
Gründe sprechen ihr oder manche
Tatsachen wie man auch in der
Philosophie sagt sprechen eher für etwas
und manche weniger das heißt es gibt
Gründe für etwas und auch Gründe gegen
das müssen sie abwählen ob etwas ein
Grund für etwas oder gegen etwas ist
hängt von der individuellen Situation
und Interessenlage der Personen ab wenn
man nicht sagt wir nehmen hier an es
gibt absolute moralische Gründe lügen
kann nie ein guter Grund sein lügen ist
immer intrinsisch schlecht
Gründe eignet sich dafür gegeneinander
abgewogen zu werden das sind Gründe
Gründe sondern sich sowie kleine
Gewichte vorstellen an gewichtssatz der
der Grund hat 15 Gramm Gewicht der Grund
hat 20 Gramm und am Ende versuchen Sie
die Gründe abzuwägen das nennt man auch
die liberieren Gründe haben also ein
normatives ein rationales und ein
motivationales Gewicht
das ist auch noch wichtig ist jetzt
natürlich metaphorisch gesprochen und
wie ich schon sagte Gründe können wir in
die Waagschalen unseres Willens legen
und irgendwann wird der Wille
ausschlagen auf eine Seite wenn Sie
sagen jetzt habe ich aber gar keine
Gründe jetzt gehen wir die Gründe aus
die guten Gründe die möglichen Gründe
die ich in Betracht ziehen kann dann
müssen sie sagen okay jetzt ist gut
jetzt schon mal wie wie schlägt er
wieder aus
und selbst wenn der Wille dann in eine
Richtung ausschlägt sich die eine
Waagschale neigt dann kann man sich
immer noch Fragen ja führt das dann
unmittelbar zu Handlung die Waagschale
die Gründe die überwiegen oder muss ich
mich selbst noch mal dann entscheiden zu
sagen okay jetzt überwiegend diese
Gründe und jetzt entscheide ich mich
auch dafür oder ist es überwiegende
Gründe selbst schon hinreichend für die
Handlung
ich würde die These Beträgen wir müssen
dann immer noch uns auch entscheiden
dafür also es noch nicht hinreichend ja
aber auch das ist eine Diskussionsrunde
wir kommen gleich zur Diskussion ich
möchte jetzt aber noch hier zum
eigentlichen heutigen Thema was wir
wieder haben wir wieder viel zu wenig
Zeit aber ich möchte es natürlich auch
noch mal ansprechen wir werden den
nächsten Sitzung natürlich noch darauf
zu sprechen kommt heute geht es um die
Frage was ist praktische Vernunft oder
Vernunft und jetzt können Sie mir
überlegen was ist überhaupt vernünftig
zu sein was bedeutet es vernünftig zu
sein ich gebe ihn jetzt mal ein paar
Beispiele an der den Sie sehen können
das was vernünftig häufig spricht man
auch von rational ist zum Beispiel wenn
sie etwas miteinander vergleichen der
Akt des Vergleichens
ist eine rationale Operation ist es
größer oder kleiner als das
ist rational Abwägen von Gründen ist
dieser Grund gewichtiger wiegt dieser
Grund schwerer oder nicht das ist auch
eine rationale Operation
bei allgemeiner wenn sie sagen
die während das wenn das jeder machen
würde und nicht nur ich also sowas wie
Extrapolation oder auch wortspinnen von
Gedanken auch ein bisschen fiktiv wie
wäre das denn wenn es alle so täten
verallgemeinern nicht nur auf meine
Interessen achten sind schauen wie wäre
es wenn alle so täten dass es
verallgemeinern und auch auf
Widersprüchlichkeit in prüfen also ich
habe jetzt hier verschiedene
Auffassungen und widersprechen die sich
vielleicht sogar ja also will ich habe
ich eigentlich ein kohärenten will auch
Widerspruchsfreiheit zu testen ist eine
Form von rational Operation natürlich
auch noch analysieren etwas in kleinere
Teile Fragen oder Probleme zu zerlegen
ist ein rationaler Akt
und natürlich nicht zuletzt Schlüsse zu
ziehen und zu urteilen ja Sie können
also ein Urteil fällen und ein Urteil
fällen sie häufig wenn Sie zu einem
Schluss gekommen sind
kann man auch wieder mit Gründen machen
das spricht dafür das spricht dafür aber
jetzt habe ich diese Interessenlage noch
und diese Situation und angesichts
dieser Situation komme ich zum Schluss
dass diese Gründe ausschlaggebend das
ist ein Schluss das ist ein praktischer
Schluss auch da brauchen sie
letztendlich ihre Vernunft dazu und noch
mal ein bisschen konkreter zu werden
wenn Sie zum Beispiel das richtige
Mittel zu einem Zweck finden und auch
wählen wollen wieder mein Beispiel ich
bin hungrig ich habe ein ganz starkes
Hungergefühl in mir
ich habe vielleicht jetzt auch den
Wunsch nichts zu essen also praktisch
wieder die Wünsche erste Stufe dann
identifiziere ich mich aber mit dem
Wunsch hier ist eine Stufe und will bei
einem Wunsch nach Befriedigung des
Hungers nachgehen also ich entwickle
eine Position zweiter Stufe und jetzt
geht's aber darum wie komme ich jetzt zu
Handlung und da muss ich jetzt
instrumentelle Vernunft und anwenden als
instrumentelle von uns heißt wenn ich
jetzt praktisch mich entschieden habe
meinem Hunger gefunden nachzugehen den
Wunsch der Wunsch etwas zu essen sondern
Wille werden
ja wie kann er denn der Wille und
handlungswirksam werden dann muss die
praktische Instrument Telefon Vernunft
einsetzen weil ich kann nicht sagen Zack
und jetzt wird mein Puls gedeckt ja
tischlein deck dich vielleicht ist es
nicht da muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
Nachdenken also was könnte ich machen ja
verschiedene Optionen jetzt kann ich
schon wieder reflektieren ich könnte
jetzt runter zur Mensa gehen aber da
gibt's nichts was mir schmeckt und da
ist immer eine Schlange dann gehe ich
lieber jetzt dahin oder ich fahre noch
kurz in die Stadt runter sie sehen jetzt
fängt ihre Vernunft an die
instrumentelle Vernunft die in
verschiedenen Möglichkeiten und Wege
aufzeigt Instrumente Mittel wie sieht
dazu kommen Ihren Wunsch zu befriedigen
oder ihren Willen auch durchzusetzen das
nennt man die instrumentelle von uns und
jetzt ist die spannende Frage gibt es
auch moralische oder praktische
moralisch praktische von uns das heißt
an unsere Vernunft nicht nur uns Mittel
zur Realisierung eines bestimmten Zwecks
geben der Zweck hängt natürlich immer
von uns ab haben wir den Wunsch oder
nicht es kann ja sein ich bin gar nicht
hungrig er muss die instrumentelle
Vernunft gar nicht so ah diese Gedanken
mehr liefern gibt es auch eine Vernunft
die mir nicht nur sagt was ich tun soll
um ein bestimmtes bestimmten Zweck zu
erreichen so eine von uns die mir sagt
tue das unabhängig von deinen
individuellen Zwecken gut das absolut
tue das weil das getan werden muss aus
moralischen Gründen und das ist sie wie
sich schon denken können die moralische
Verlust die nennt man nach Immanuel Kant
den kategorischen Imperativ es gibt
hypothetische imperative hypothetisch
von griechisch heißt einfach bedingte
imperative unter einer Bedingung
stehende Befehle also
instrumentelle Vernunft etwas zu essen
mir jetzt darunter zu gehen was zu
kaufen diese Imperativ gilt nur wenn ich
Hunger habe und kategorische imperative
die gelten einfach unbedingt die gelten
absolut kategorisch und es ist der
Unterschied darauf hat Immanuel Kanton
gewesen dass wir diesen zwischen diesen
zweien Formen imperativen unterscheiden
müssen und es handelt sich dabei
letztendlich auch um Formen unserer
Vernunft kategorisch und hypothetisch
imperative sind verschiedene
operationsweisen Anwendung unserer hier
sagt er das in seiner Grundlegung zu
Metaphysik der Sitten alle Imperativ
also alle Befehle alle Normen die wir in
unserer von uns vernehmen können sind
wir wieder hypothetisch oder kategorisch
am jene also die hypothetischen stellen
die praktische Notwendigkeit also die
Handlungsnotwendigkeit einer möglichen
Handlung als Mittel zu etwas anderem was
man will zu gelangen vor also ich habe
Hunger möchte mein Hunger und der
Imperativ sagt mir dann geh doch auf der
Wasser ist der kategorische Imperativ
würde der sein welche eine Handlung als
für sich selbst ohne Beziehung auf einen
anderen Zweck als objektiv notwendig
vorstellt also tue das einfach
schlechthin weil es gut ist zum Beispiel
Lüge niemals ja das wäre nach Kant ein
Beispiel des kategorischen parativs also
hypothetische Imperativ hat die Form
wenn du x erreichen möchtest dann musst
du dafür y tun wenn du dein Hungergefühl
befriedigen möchtest dann musst du dir
jetzt hier was kaufen musst du etwas zu
essen besorgen zum Beispiel könnte auch
was anderes sein ja da musst Du hier dir
vom Nachbarn Nachbarn musste dir dann
das Brötchen klauen
also Mittel zweckrelation der
kategorische Imperativ sagt tue x
unbedingt und nicht nur
wenn Du etwas anderes erreichen möchtest
ja also genau genommen hätte ich
schreiben müssen Pool y unbedingt
und nicht nur wenn du ein X erreichen
möchtest ja zum Beispiel du sollst
jemals Lügen lügen kann in keinem
Kontext ein gutes Mittel zum Erreichen
eines zwecks sein zum Beispiel eine
angenehme Atmosphäre zu schaffen das
sagt kann wir kommen jetzt gleich noch
auf die Diskussion ich möchte ihn
nämlich jetzt noch eine eine Alternative
geben Immanuel Kant sagt die Vernunft
selbst die praktische vernünftige
gebietet dass wir manche Dinge niemals
tun sollen oder manche Dinge absolut tun
sollen nämlich wir sollen niemals lügen
sagt markant uns die Vernunft die
moralischen oder anders gewinnen wir
sollen immer die Wahrheit sagen es ist
nach Kant auch ein absolutes Gebot
selbst wenn wir dabei eine Person retten
könnten die von einem Mörder verfolgt
wurden selbst wenn uns der Mörder fragt
hat die Person bei der Unterschrift
gefunden
dürfen sie nicht lügen um das Leben der
Person zu retten machen kannst und sie
müssen den Mörder sagen ja sie ist hier
rein in mein
Haus also Notlüge geht nach kann nicht
selbst wenn ich das Leben einer Person
retten möchte und das sagt kann gebietet
uns die Vernunft
und jetzt kann man sich fragen ja ist
die Vernunft wirklich so
moralisch kann die sowas er sagt es gibt
eine alternativposition David jung David
jung ist ein englischer Philosoph der
sagt wir drücken uns nicht genau und für
einen schottischer Philosoph genau wir
drücken uns nicht genau und
philosophisch Aussehen von einem Kampf
zwischen Affekt und Vernunft reden die
Vernunft ist nur das klar bitte Effekte
und soll es sein sie darf niemals eine
andere Funktion beanspruchen als die
denselben zu dienen zu gehorchen also
jung sagt es gibt nur instrumentale von
uns es gibt niemals von uns die selbst
unseren Willen bestimmt
jetzt kommt noch mal was lustiges es
läuft der Vernunft nicht zuwider wenn
ich lieber die Zerstörung der ganzen
Welt will als ein Ritz muss das heißen
an meinem Finger ist widerspricht nicht
der Vernunft wenn ich meinen
vollständigen Ruin auf mich nehme um das
kleinste Unbehagen eines Indianers oder
einer mir gänzlich unbekannten Person zu
verhindern es verstößt ebenso wenig
gegen die Vernunft wenn ich das
erkanntermaßen für mich weniger gute dem
besseren vorziehe und zu dem ersteren
die größeren Neigung empfinde also ist
es wirklich nicht unvernünftig wenn ich
lieber die Zerstörung der ganzen Welt
will als ein Ritz an meinem Finger hast
können wir uns das überlegen ist das
wirklich nicht unvernünftig sowas zu
wollen und da lade ich es jetzt zu einer
kurzen Abstimmung ein